[Música]
y seguimos sobre este tema en economía
por supuesto con daniela blandón danny
ya viernes finalizamos la semana pero
solo falta un paso para que la deuda
argentina con el fm quede finalmente
refinanciada no así de raúl e muy buen
viernes para usted feliz día el congreso
argentino entonces aprobó este por
mayorías de acuerdo al que llegó el
gobierno de alberto fernández con el
fondo monetario internacional y que lo
que busca es que se paguen 45 mil
millones de dólares de una deuda
contraída por el ejecutivo anterior de
mauricio macri ahora sólo falta raúl la
aprobación final por parte del organismo
con sede en washington ojalá antes del
20 de marzo porque ese día vence un
nuevo plazo y argentina debería en
teoría pagar unos 2 mil 900 millones de
dólares es decir que si para ese
entonces no está completamente cerrado
el pacto el país se expone a un
incumplimiento oa un default o ahora
veamos con este nuevo acuerdo de
financiamiento el gobierno es para tener
un respiro ya que su próximo desembolso
sería en 2026 y seguiría los pagos hasta
2034 el gobierno sostiene que el acuerdo
no requeriría ninguna revisión del
sistema de pensiones ni de las normas
laborales pero dice que obligaría a
aumentar los precios del gas la
electricidad y otros servicios públicos
por eso es que la gente también está tan
molesta raúl seguimos en nuestra región
porque hay más noticias económicas han y
claro que si en brasil la actividad
económica se contrajo un 0,99 por ciento
en enero frente a diciembre del año
pasado está en su mayor retroceso en los
últimos 10 meses y se da en un contexto
de altísimas tasas de interés y de una
inflación de más del 10 por ciento
interanual y para nadie es un secreto
que occidente quiere aislar a rusia del
comercio internacional por todo lo que
está pasando en la guerra en ucrania
claro pues la cámara baja de eeuu tomó
el paso más reciente y aprobó y envió al
senado una legislación que les quitaría
a rusia y belarús el estatus comercial
de nación más favorecida esto allanaría
el camino para imponer más aranceles
sobre los productos provenientes de esos
países dejemos que sea
y la vocera de la cámara baja quien lo
explica
con este proyecto de ley eeuu suspenderá
permanentemente las relaciones
comerciales normales con rusia lo que
significa que nunca volverán a disfrutar
del tratamiento arancelario preferencial
haremos que sea lo más difícil posible
para rusia hacer negocios con eeuu y
nuestros aliados
y también suspenderemos las relaciones
comerciales normales con belarús por su
vergonzosa complicidad en la agresión de
rusia y danny pérez que también
occidente ha tenido dificultades para
poder castigar a rusia cuáles han sido
estas pues mire aparte o más allá de las
sanciones que occidente ha querido
imponer a rusia también quiere atacar
uno de los flancos que consideran más
frágiles dentro del kremlin y que son
los oligarcas o magnates allegados a
vladimir putin el presidente aunque se
han anunciado duros castigos estados
unidos y sus aliados ahora luchan por
perseguir con éxito esos lujosos bienes
como superyates o mansiones pero estas
investigaciones podrían tardar meses
años y se corre el peligro de
inmovilizar o activos equivocados y es
que los multimillonarios rusos han
tenido décadas para proteger su dinero y
activos para evitar que los gobiernos de
occidente pues intenten ponerles
impuestos o incluso embargar lo usted
tiene ejemplos específicos cuáles son
mire este que llamativo raúl el enorme
súper yate dilbar de casi 700 millones
de dólares que van a ver en sus
pantallas se extiende a lo largo de un
campo de fútbol tiene dos helipuertos y
tiene una piscina de 25 metros de largo
las autoridades alemanas lo intentaron
confiscar porque pertenece al magnate
ruso de los metales alisher usmánov sin
embargo el ministerio de economía del
estado de hamburgo aseguró que todavía
no ha podido embargarle porque no ha
podido establecer la propiedad del yate
a pesar de que oiga esto raúl tiene el
nombre de la madre de usmánov que es del
bar en estos casos lo que hacen es
registrarlos a nombre de empresas de
papel en paraísos fiscales dicen las
autoridades aunque en el círculo cercano
pues se sabe quién es el dueño y digamos
también los llamados testaferros
con todo esto que está pasando en el
mundo en materia económica
cómo están los mercados las bolsas
europeas se mueven este viernes a la
baja guiadas en parte por los precios
del petróleo que vuelven a subir por
encima de los 100 dólares por barril
las bolsas asiáticas están mixtas el
principal índice de la bolsa de tokio
tuvo leves ganancias después de que el
banco central decidiera mantener la
política monetaria intacta enapu la
bueno danny y la cifra el día nos la
queda debiendo el peso con deuda una muy
buena estima está esta mañana de viernes
la debe y no las dice entonces en el
próximo bloque economía vamos a ver el
reportaje